c'est la plus grande fusion jamais
réalisée c'est aussi une révolution dans
le monde des médias et c'est le dossier
du 19/20 ce soir aol et time warner ont
annoncé leur mariage hier concrètement
cela veut dire qu internet deviendra le
grand média du futur que l'on pourra y
trouver des banques de données bien sûr
mais aussi des journaux ou encore du
cinéma explications de lionel que tu es
benoît vers en
martinique sein des derniers succès de
la warner bientôt disponible sur votre
écran d'ordinateur grâce au web voilà ce
qui vous attend grâce à la fusion entre
aol et time warner internet s'empare des
médias à vous de cliquer je suis
français de base à tarbes ok et j'aurai
tout le catalogue de la grand mère je
paierai un dollar pour voir le fils il
m'arrivera en plein écran sur mon pc qui
sera plus un pc au sens strict du terme
ce sera un écran plat dans deux ans vous
aurez des écrans plats tout beau tout
bête qui vous mettre dans votre salon
kim arriveront plein écran qualité des
achats sur bien sûr le cinéma n'est pas
le seul média que vous pourrez regarder
sur votre ordinateur car la warner s'est
également des chaînes de télé comme si
nl et des dessins animés ou encore des
magazines de presse écrite aujourd'hui
il suffit d'avoir un ordinateur et une
connexion internet par le câble par
satellite ou par le téléphone les
techniques évoluent très rapidement la
bande passante faire les tuyaux qui vont
avec comme les tuyaux d'eau robinet
culture il est petit en section effet
pas passé beaucoup d'eau et plus
l'hérault vous fait passer beaucoup
d'eau il ya de plus en plus de mon
client le futur audiovisuel semble donc
un partenaire dorénavant à internet
aoued l'a bien compris sa fusion avec
time warner en est la preuve les deux
pdg y trouvent leur compte le web est un
formidable outil de distribution pour la
warner et aol espère bien augmenter le
nombre de ses abonnés qui dépasse déjà
les 20 millions grâce au nouveau
programme qu'il pourra proposer